this might be one of the most
interesting charts that i've seen around
bitcoin in a while
glassnode which is a data provider uh
for a lot of the on-chain data
tweeted this out yesterday and i spent a
lot of time looking at it
and i spent a lot of time talking to
people about it and
then i talked to joe and john about it
all morning and i think it might be one
of the most important charts
in all of bitcoin at the moment and so
what this chart shows
is the proportions between long and
short-term
holder supply so what it basically does
and look you see all the squiggly lines
everywhere like when you look at it like
it must be important it's got squiggly
lines going all over the place
there's three lines may not be able to
tell there's only three lines there's a
blue line
a pink line and a black line blue pink
black
the blue line is the long-term
holders people have been holding bitcoin
for at least
a year the pink line is the short-term
holders it's supposed to say s-t-h it
says l-t-h on pink
they made a mistake no problem s-t-h is
the pink
lth is the blue long-term holders in
blue
short-term holders in pink the black
line in the background that is the price
of
bitcoin from a logarithmic standpoint
and so when you lay these three lines on
top of each other what you can see is
going all the way back to 2013
when bitcoin hit a
long-term holder supply of 63
that led shortly thereafter to a bull
market
you then can see that the supply of
long-term holders
dropped as the price went up and then it
kind of waffled back and forth you see
that word right there joe waffled
and then all of a sudden we get to the
end of 2016
and again we get a long term holder
percentage of 71 percent when we get the
71 percent
bam price explodes upwards and then as
you see the price going up
in 2017 what happens is the amount of
long-term holders goes down because
people are selling the bitcoin
into the market they see price going up
and at certain price points people are
willing to sell bitcoin that previously
weren't willing to sell
so long-term holders hit 71.5 beginning
of 2017.
bam all of a sudden price takes off
people start to sell their bitcoin into
the bull market
so we come back we see again in april of
2019
same exact effect there is a 67
long-term holder supply and then we get
a bull market
and then in october of 2020 long-term
holders hit
68 percent 68.2 percent bam bull market
now it goes without saying that history
is not a predictor of future performance
but the reason why this chart is so
fascinating
is because glass node was able to take a
look at this and understand
that whenever that long-term oh excuse
me that long-term holder supply
is between 63.6 and 71.5
often we get a bull market in the
months after now that does not mean it's
guaranteed
that does not mean that it always
happens you can see in 2015 or so we
were there for a while
at very high levels of long-term holders
and eventually we then got a bull market
so timing hard to tell the exact
kind of sequence of events though a
pretty good historical
comparison and so right now where are we
if you look on the far right of this
chart we are at 66
so between 63 and 71 and a half percent
that tends to lead to the bull markets
or kind of large increases in price
we're at 66 percent we just came back
from that big dip
and now we have entered basically the
middle of that bracket
and so this is another data point that
continues to show
what we're watching is strong hands
people who hold for a long period of
time they're not trading they're not
selling bitcoin they continue to
accumulate bitcoin
and they're holding it for that long
period of time when that happens
this is just a simple another data point
another chart that contributes to the
supply
squeeze thesis if history repeats itself
which there's no guarantee that it will
but if it does
we will point back and say the long-term
holder to short-term holder
proportional supply was a no-brainer
that indicated that price was going to
go up
we'll see what happens but joe john as
two bitcoiners over there
people that are long bitcoin what's
what's the thoughts on the chart i like
the chart
i'm a big fan of the chart i happen to
like the chart too do we think that
uh do we think that it's a reliable
source uh of data in terms of uh
indicating what it what is
probabilistically likely to happen
yeah i think uh what's the saying when
like kana in the disclosures where
they're like uh
you know past performance is not
indicative of future results
and that's true uh so i think you
obviously want to take all these things
kind of with a grain of salt and judge
for yourself
but any time you can back test a set of
data and look at it for future
experiences and to kind of determine
what the uh
especially in the case of supply and
demand right an asset that derives a lot
of its value from supply and demand i
think it's super
important and useful so these charts i
think when you look at them in a
combination of all the on-chain metrics
whether it's uh the supply or the
uh kind of the the test away from uh
you know the last halving and all that
kind of stuff whatever chart you're
looking at you look at them in unison
and kind of all
comprehensive uh but i think they're
helpful yeah
john yeah i'm a long-term thinker so
seeing people hold it uh for more than
years definitely an indication of
almost a slight conviction in the asset
um they think it's gonna go up and
they're not
just day trading or anything like that
so i think it's very positive for
bitcoin and excited to see where it goes
from here
i it's a little hard to tell exactly can
we pop the chart one more time maybe i
can see it on the other screen but
uh if we look at it what's fascinating
to me on the far
left side here um let's see if i can
actually
see what these numbers are so on the far
uh
is it the left side or maybe it's the
right side that we have to look um
the percentage never really seems to
drop
below a certain number right so the
percentage of long-term holders
actually has been uh maybe like 50
we've had long-term holders stay above
50 which to me is really interesting
because uh when we have above 50
of all bitcoin being held for what
appears to be
a decade or so right really since like
2011 2012
we've never dipped below that 50 or kind
of bounced right off of 50
long-term holders that explains why over
long periods of time the asset continues
to do really well
it's because there's this base of uh of
kind of bitcoin believers that just are
not
providing any liquidity to the market
they're not going to sell that so even
though there's 18.8 million bitcoin that
are in circulation
they're not willing to put those bitcoin
into the market or they're lost right
doesn't mean that
investors could be lost as well uh and
then all of a sudden you say hey look
there's actually only nine million or so
bitcoin
that actually are even possible for uh
sale or or for being turned over over
almost a decade
and then when you start looking at 66
haven't traded hands in a year
you can see both kind of the shorter
term and the longer term both end up
being really attractive
so a lot of people uh you know you can
talk through the store of value
and uh kind of all the stuff related to
currencies and transparency and every
all the other kind of aspects that
people talk about with bitcoin and its
value
but when it comes to supply and demand
is this just like the greatest
uh supply and demand trade that you've
ever seen
i mean first let's just look at like is
it the greatest trade period
yeah and over the last decade or so
bitcoin has been the best investment you
could have made
uh so that's one piece of it the second
piece is supply demand
structure in a market determines price
right yeah as supplier demand moves so
does price
what is unique about bitcoin and why
bitcoin likely is
the simplest supply demand
trade in history is that
the supply is programmatic right take
gold as an example
we kind of sort of know how much gold
exists we kind of sort of know how much
gold's coming out of the ground
we kind of sort of hope that we're not
gonna go mine asteroids of gold
etc and we kind of sort of hope that no
one finds a big deposit of gold
yeah but for the most part we have a
highly educated guess as to how much
gold's in the world
how much gold is coming out of the
ground on the annual basis
bitcoin we know exactly i can verify
i can tell you to the bitcoin how much
bitcoin is in circulation
i can show you on a blockchain exactly
900 bitcoin are coming into circulation
every single day
and so when you can verify it and
there's full transparency
what it does is it makes you much more
accurate
about predicting price movements in the
future and so
with bitcoin specifically you not only
get full
transparency and uh kind of
verifiability
but you also then get pre-programmed
changes to the supply
so that bitcoin having that happens
every four years you know there's going
to be a supply shock every four years
everyone in the market doesn't know that
as well and so
what's occurred over the last decade is
if you simply understood how bitcoin was
designed you understood the structure
then you were able to capture the
benefits of increasing demand for a
disinflationary asset
that had a fully constricted supply at
21 million
and only 18 million or so are in
circulation now about 18.8 million
and on top of that that disinflationary
supply continues to drive down
and create more and more difficulty of
acquiring bitcoin which leads to
as long as demand continues to increase
bitcoin price has to appreciate to
accommodate everyone
and that has been the trade for the last
decade if you did that you did better
than almost any other asset in the world
if not
every other asset in the world and i
don't think that's gonna stop anytime
soon
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it